there are new questions this morning
about reservations the Trump transition
team had with the president's former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
Flynn resigned from the post after he
was caught misleading the administration
about his contacts with the Russian
government we are now learning that last
November the Trump transition team asked
the Obama White House for the classified
CIA profile of Russia's ambassador to
the US they seemed concerned about the
ambassador's contacts with Flynn a
Senate committee investigating Russian
interference with last year's election
has asked Flynn for information related
to its investigation president Trump is
spending the weekend away from the White
House savoring his first success in the
repeal of Obamacare the house managed to
pass a bill to replace the affordable
care act this week by a margin of just
four votes but the bills future is in
doubt as Senate Republicans are crafting
their own version of the measure
Errol Barnett is traveling with the
president in New Jersey Errol good
morning good morning yes president Trump
is continuing a long weekend at his bed
Minster New Jersey Golf property not too
far from where I am after finally
scoring a legislative win the house
passage of the American Health Care Act
on Thursday now gives the administration
and achievement it can point to even
though the effort to fully repeal and
replace Obamacare is far from over
on Thursday the House voted to repeal
one of the worst job-killing laws of all
it's called Obamacare perhaps you've
heard of it the bill is passed and
without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid upon the table the
celebration was sweet but short for the
President and GOP House members who
passed the American Health Care Act
after a rose garden ceremony mr. Trump
left Washington and the house began its
week-long break that leaves the bill in
the hands of a skeptical Senate there
the bills path is expected to be rocky
the total cost of the House bill is
still unknown and a working group of 13
senators all men has already been formed
to make changes White House spokeswoman
Sarah Huckabee Sanders
the president will not rush the Senate
this is a process we haven't put a
timeline or a deadline we want to get it
right not get it fast and that's the
that's the focus one big issue for the
Senate the GOP plan includes sweeping
changes to Medicaid it would put caps on
Medicaid funding starting in 2020 and
stop payments to Obamacare's expansion
of Medicaid to people just above the
poverty line this would leave the 31
states and the District of Columbia that
participated in the Medicaid expansion
to fund the coverage themselves cut
benefits or cut enrollment President
Trump is also drawing criticism for this
comment made Thursday while meeting with
Australian Prime Minister Malcolm
Turnbull in New York I shouldn't say
this to our great gentleman and my
friend from Australia because you have
better health care than we do Trump
repeated his admiration on Twitter
Friday writing of course the Australians
have better health care than we do
everybody does now back to the Senate
the Republican majority body could pass
its version of health care reform
without any support from Democrats
through a process called reconciliation
but that process could take time as the
details are ironed out and as many
Republican senators envision major
changes of their own
Anthony Errol Barnett with the president
in New Jersey thanks Errol for